chacun jean paul rouve
là
jean paul rault messieurs jean paul
rault or dix mois en préparant
sathienthirakul je regardais tata
filmographie 80 cinéma et c'est déjà
très très bien serial lover le petit
poucet tanguy astérix et obélix mission
cléopâtre il influence monsieur tu la
gelée pas 10 parce que quand même tu
vois je devrais dire vis-à-vis de
dominique farrugia
ben ouais parce que j'en suis chien
aussi attendait fier aussi mais où est
ce que ça prend les femmes on propose un
euro la nuit dernière
mais dites le moi ni mon cours la
semaine dernière alors que la lettonie a
dit j'ai fait deux films non je ne sais
pas le meilleur des devoirs ouais
monsieur batignole moi césar 10 ans et
demi mais qui a tué pamela rose podium
un long dimanche de fiançailles je
préfère qu'on reste amis le temps des
porte-plumes et nos jours heureux dont
nous allons parler ce soir c'est pas mal
à la sava et coûtera pas mal une autre
chaîne
la bande annonce de ton fils nos jours
heureux oui ouais ça donne envie de le
voir il est bien c'est très rare merci
un avc / garder un nom mais ça fait
super plaisir n'en est encore rien vu il
validera de la môme la vie de piaf dont
harbin chine a dit le plus grand bien
ici c'est quand même pas rien
il était là quand il l'a vu à cannes en
partie là du le promo reel à kabala il
adore écoute vraiment pour quelqu'un qui
supportait pas de se voir à l'écran ça
va mieux là tu étais habitué aujourd'hui
avoir ta gueule à s'habituer oui oui
c'était un excès de coquetterie
ouais ça va maintenant c'est bon quoi je
vois ça c'est un t-shirt du film c'est
pour rebecca abel peu le mec tout de
suite mais j'aimerais qu'elle le mail se
change devant nous
ah oui ça va à un bébé car voilà que je
m'oppose à temps on estime qu'on ferme
les yeux brillants on est comme des
garçons plus les cartes à dire incluant
on veut fermer les yeux
ultime il suffirait de changer and on
and on m'a alors alors va être changée
de normal non changer la place alors
mécanique et j'aurais essayé
j'aurais essayé mais tu vas ne veut pas
se changer à l'attenté n'est pas idiot
jean paul fayault d'armes peut-être
c'est câliner la grande copine de
sarkozy c'est vrai il va bien six mille
personnes ce soir il a un film qui sort
des pétards plus de pub chez toi je fume
pas de thématique du one man alors bien
vous êtes devenu une star jean paul
ah bon barges en bal à 20 minutes
d'accord en premiers mois les gars